get your dicks ready everyone
whip it out ladies hi welcome to another
episode of big mood
you guys all did that thing and i didn't
do it i'm sorry i filled it out
yeah yeah
as you guys can see we're back in our
old pajamas
she threw it i still didn't i still yeah
i threw it away the spirit is cool it's
okay i still appreciate it
we're all in our pajamas again yeah you
can see we're very cozy
and comfy it's like a slumber party it's
like a slumber potty did we come up with
a name for this
no we didn't moods and queues
there were so many suggestions all
that's right
yeah there were like in my dm's they
they came through
uh like one that i remember seeing was a
big or no big ask mood or something
big ass big-ass moves mood yeah that was
a big ask
oh yeah i kind of like that one it's
very clever it's a big-ass mood in here
yeah uh so today's episode we're going
to be answering your questions that we
had you guys ask us
on instagram and we picked out a few
really good ones and
some really silly ones and we're going
to answer it together here
as friends i'm still trying to figure
out if i that tequila is still working
so please don't mind me
to curl up i think it's working it's
still working
apparently so it's still working so
thank you guys for uh
asking us so many questions and uh let's
let's [ __ ] just
swing right into it guys [ __ ] it okay
big mood swinging the big mood swinging
uh paula would like to ask
how do you give a friend advice when you
know that she's wrong
ooh i think that's a good friend so my
measurement of
a good for or a good friend a great
friend a good friend is there for you
to like comfort you and stuff but a
great friend is someone that's going to
tell you the truth
even if it hurts yeah you know i don't
think i'll ever reach great friend
potential because for me
like what like i i see
my friends as like they're 100 correct
and like
i don't know that's so wrong of me
because obviously it's not a good friend
it's like you can't even see the wrong
but like as soon as something is
happening or whatever
i i don't i always view it from the lens
of like
that's them that's how they think that's
correct you know what i've seen
from you though is when two of your
friends are having a little bit of an
argument
you can give good insight to how
each side is feeling so like you can
kind of guide
um where you feel them more strongly
you know i've seen you do that before
cool yeah but yeah like to actually call
you guys out on something wrong
like i i wouldn't see it until after and
then i'm like
oh yeah i guess that was wrong but in
the moment though i i
don't i can't see it i think it's
because you know like your friend's
intentions and stuff you know so it's
like
um like if gina says something like if
gina roasts me about something i'm like
i know she's not actually insulting me
so if she roasts someone else i know
she's not insulting them but maybe they
didn't know that
and so it's harder for me to call her
out on that because i'm like i'm just
seeing
it from the perspective of the person i
know true yeah maybe that's what it is
i have done that thing where like i i
really need yeah
i need um like if i'm going through
something like if it's like a
relationship or a disagreement with
someone that's a family friend or
whatever
uh i hit you guys up and i do my best to
tell both sides of the story unbiasedly
as i possibly could no matter how i'm
feeling
and i always ask am i being crazy like
if i'm wrong please let me know yeah
i really need to know if i'm really
wrong here and there are times when you
guys are like hey
yeah you kind of [ __ ] up dude and that
is what i appreciate so much because i
can't have yes men around me all the
time that's true because you can't
create
create growth that's why that's why i
kind of feel bad a bit
for the way i see it no but but like the
way i see
things if it's if it's wrong like for
example just you're the
you're so good at like calling [ __ ] out
and you're like
wait that's not right i'm just [ __ ]
judgy as [ __ ] i'm like always telling
people what to do
but that's so appreciated because like
yeah you can't grow if it is just yes
man so that's why i kind of struggle a
little bit where i'm like [ __ ]
i don't know how to like remove that
veil i guess that i see
in front of like my eyes with friends
because like for me it's like they can
do no wrong
you have a bias i do yeah i get that
yeah it comes from a place of
natural yeah yeah but i really
appreciate it when you when i ask you
guys and you guys really do tell me the
truth and that's how you know it's a
good friend
because i mean as a good friend you
don't want to
lead your friend down the wrong path you
know like yeah you want to be nice to
them and tell them that they're right
but that's
in the long run it's not it doesn't help
them it's not good for them
exactly mm-hmm so i i'm really glad i
have you i think um and so to answer
your question how to give a friend
advice when i know she's wrong
do it lightly like you know you don't
don't feel like you're wrong
yeah like consider that your friend is
feeling emotions
and so take those into consideration and
and be like you know i know you're
feeling blank right now
but maybe you should look at it um this
way and
see if that changes your perspective on
anything you know something like that
yeah or consider if you're only um
acting with emotion and
and maybe i can help inject a little bit
of logic right
but also sometimes people just really
aren't ready to hear a solution
like so it doesn't matter like you can
maybe you just back off and
eventually she'll be ready for it i
don't know if people are just trying to
vent then
it's you can't really like interject
with a solution
right let them vent first and then if
they're really like what should i do
right then you're like okay well if you
want my honest opinion
you know this is what i think yeah i
think the best way to do it is to try to
help your friends see it in the other
person's shoes
like do you get why it feels a little
bit weird on this side now how you might
be wrong
so that's a that's i think that's a
gentle way of doing it yeah yeah
uh the next question is from joe d
shepherd
oh i love you i see him a lot hi joe oh
hi hi joe what's up fam
hi he's not creepy right no oh cool we
love each other he hates people though
and that's what i love about him what up
joe
um joe asks what's it like to date
people in different cultural backgrounds
oh i've only had one experience in this
yeah
and it was like for me personally i
don't know
i don't know if this is wrong but i
actually got turned on even more
learning from a different like learning
a different culture every time like
casey would be speaking cantonese i'm
like oh my god that's a turn on i don't
know why
i think a lot of people are like that
yeah yeah because like i
i liked that when joe when we would go
to japan and he would speak
japanese i would be like wow it's like a
special skill
yeah it's like special
he said it's like uh
yeah it makes people special so yeah
it's not weird to
to be turned on i think by the the only
reason why i feel weird about it is
because some
fetish thing yeah yeah yeah it's like
fetishizing i mean
because you're not like serially dating
chinese guys like you just happen to
have a husband that's
from chinese background and yeah you
respect it and you think it's cool and
it is
yeah it was hard for me well not hard
i dated one white guy once and it was
like he was like nice enough but i kind
of something in me like craved
some sort of familiarity like hey have
you ever gotten the [ __ ] beaten out of
you and kneeled on some raw rice before
like oh no
well you know like it's it's just
something that we can bond over
to i can relate to that sentiment
because i do miss
like i didn't realize this until like
years later but i'm like oh my god
i feel like deprived of my own culture
because i've been so like fascinated
with
with his culture that i ended up kind of
losing myself a bit
so i feel the same way because um i i've
only dated
one or two white guys i mean unless you
want to count hit like mexican guys as
white guys because
you get really deep into that racial
talk but honestly there's a cultural
leader there's a different
culture right with mexican guys versus
white
guys and i've dated mostly mexican guys
and uh
you know a japanese guy um but then uh
recently i've been kind of trying to
date
white guys again i mean before
quarantine i'm kind of [ __ ] now i kind
of had a french guy for a little they
were french
there's a huge cultural difference in
that but yeah i i i realized that
i like i'm like why am i not dating any
white guys and then i did date a couple
and i was like oh this does feel a
little bit
like familiar and comfortable um i
haven't been able to make a
relationship work with the white guy yet
but i would like to just
i don't know it really doesn't matter
though yeah it doesn't really matter i
just i just craved it
you know like there are some parts of me
like i call your parents by their first
name that's
i don't know some things are just like
so different where you're like yeah
so i lean more towards asian like not
even just specifically vietnamese
but more towards the asian side i think
the only time i experienced a
i guess a little bit of a cultural
difference because i did date a filipino
guy but that's still like
i'm half filipino half white so i dated
white guys and i did a filipino guy
but then i also dated this german guy
who's white technically
but when we say white i think we mean
white american yeah like
uh culturally he his his uh
parents were from germany like from
germany so they still had like
german things and like the german they
would make german food and
have german names for things and like so
i i think i thought it was cute but he
was
he was american though so i don't really
feel like it went that much
into a different culture it was just
when we spent time with his parents and
stuff
yeah okay so the next question is from
four four four x zero zero okay this is
elon musk's second child
um he has like five kids wait does he
yeah he has a ton of kids he's been
married and divorced like three times oh
i had no idea all right either
yeah all i know is grimes and we should
know i remember having a crush on him
and then seeing his like marriage
and divorce rate like over and over he
keeps getting married and divorced and
i'm like oh
never mind he actually lost a kid i
don't remember i remember looking into
anyway i had no idea he's got a history
shout out to tesla's talk thanks baby i
love you
yeah um
so let's uh they want to know can you
give us some first
date best advice brush your teeth
worse than cologne relax relax
i think the main thing about first dates
is like not trying to get the other
person to like you
but like actually being yourself and see
if you like how you feel around them
because
for for me i think when i first started
dating again after five
[ __ ] years i was like oh i i want to
make sure he likes me
you know but that's like totally [ __ ]
pointless who cares if he likes you you
want to know that you want someone that
accepts you yeah yeah you want to know
if you like him
right and opposite for the guy you want
to know that she likes you not just like
trying to put on a face too
it changes when you're older too because
now you're like look i don't got time to
wait
or waste you know also that person
doesn't know what you like so i don't
like when people put on this
fake version of what they think you're
gonna like because you don't know what i
like
assuming i like weird [ __ ] it feels so
manipulative yeah
to to try to like figure out you and
like unlock you as a puzzle and it's
like
what the [ __ ] like it just feels like
manipulation so i don't like that just
be yourself but don't divulge too much
information
like don't get into the weird dark [ __ ]
oh i like that [ __ ]
really we do just be as honest as
possible what i did on the first date
was just like ask
the deepest questions just to see if
they can handle it because if they can't
handle it then i don't know
i don't really think sometimes the first
date might be a little bit
too much like it depends on the guy
maybe the second or third
oh and i've also only dated or went on
dates with guys that i was friends with
first
yeah so you kind of already knew that
yeah but like just to cold like
tell someone all of your trauma is
usually like that's your first
impression of that person is that
they're broken
and even if they are too it's kind of
like oh that's a lot
to deal with on the first date yeah i
think if i would ever date again that's
that's like what i would want is just
like pure honesty because i
feel like that's just what i'm going to
give so it's like here can you handle it
cool let me get get yours is a little
bit of a game it really is and like the
longer you're
in it the more you realize it is a
little bit of a game see that's
something i just can't
yeah like wrap my head around because
i've never been in that dating game but
i don't
like to if i would ever be in that
situation i wouldn't want to play the
game
it just feels so fake to me and i i
wouldn't want to be like
fake to someone else or have them be
fake to me well it's not i wouldn't call
it fake i think it's like
say you get a new job right like say all
of this [ __ ] went away and you had to go
get a new job like you wouldn't tell
your boss on the first day like
everything about you you would try to
make a good impression and then like
that over time you would tell your
co-workers more and more about yourself
over time as you're building friendships
i think it's the same with dating it's
like
it's not really being fake it's just
like giving people too much at once
is like a lot okay that is a difference
yeah i'm cool with that i don't think
it's being fake
yeah but for sure i just don't agree
with the
let me figure out what you like and let
me do what you guys do
towards getting you because i've gotten
that yeah oh and then you find out
afterwards there were nothing like the
first date
yeah the catfish no as in game when i
say game i don't really mean a game i
think just more like you i have to
understand pacing and i get that
by the way i don't mean tell telling
everybody everything on the first date
for me it's like it goes to more of a
philosophical questions and i like to
see how they answer them because
yeah if if you're if you can't have
a deeper conversation then what's your
job like and like
right i'm bored of you yeah maybe it
doesn't have to be so personal
just like just something philosophical i
did i went on a second date with this
guy and i said what should we do
with the homeless people like how can we
help the home like because i was just
kind of like
trying to figure out how he could answer
like how does he think or what's his
mental process
so maybe if you could think of some
questions that will get a better insight
into how
because then you might learn that
they're super racist or something like
immediately you'll find out some [ __ ]
like a question i would ask was um
what's your biggest regret and how did
you get over it yeah that's great
yeah jesus christ wow
they don't have to tell me their biggest
regret they can tell me some other thing
i just want to see how they answer the
question and like
what their sort of personality is like
to
you know get out of something like that
or maneuver it or what their
you know it goes into philosophy of how
you get over things in life you know if
they can match you into like i think
yeah
as i got older it really got to the
point where like the first day i'd be
all right so what are you
looking for out of this so then it
really oh yeah all the questions that
you need like
and you're not wasting time though no
because people don't know on the first
day sometimes
well no because like no because there's
people that go into a date knowing like
i really just want to hook up and not
get in a relationship any time soon
because that could change
that could change that could change in
like three weeks they could be like oh
my god this girl's perfect i'm going to
marry her
but they wouldn't know that on the first
day which happens all the time no it's
always in the first date with me
like that then i'm not sure like yeah
i'm kind of just like
putting some feels out yeah and like and
i would appreciate it if they were like
um i just wanted like if it's like i
want to see where this goes because like
i'm
open to a relationship or if they're
just straight up like
i just got out of a relationship i'm
just looking to have some fun like i
like
that because then it doesn't leave me
like oh where is this going
with no like expectations and like if
you are if they think that oh now we're
exclusive off this first date and you
don't see it that way
it's good to know yeah so being on the
same page is important yeah
but like more more on like a like
surface level
i'd say uh make sure you're asking
questions and not just only talking
i thought you were gonna say huh make
sure your ass is clean
but that too if you're planning on
having sex on the first date you better
make sure that ass is clean
you never know that too it's just like a
job interview
um the best job interviews i've ever had
are where i am
yes so my ass is clean and i'm asking
questions as well as them i've noticed
that
because um i think in january i went to
get uh
i was gonna go get a job actually in
january i was gonna go get an accounting
job before i decided wait i'm gonna get
my license first but i went in
and i started asking this [ __ ]
questions and then and then she
just like seemed more interested in me
because i was asking her all these
questions so
people everyone everyone everyone is a
narcissist on some level so everyone
wants to
feel important so if you're asking
questions you're making that person feel
important like making them
like sharing also you get to know like
you get a lot of info
and info when you're not just the only
one talking yeah yeah you need info
yeah it's true and it's a two-way street
you have to like your job and the job
has to like you
same with dating and don't drone on holy
crap i've had people drawn on oh my god
i will actually make it a game like
let's see how long it takes for them to
realize that i haven't answered they
haven't asked me a single question
no i hate that um other than that keep
your ass clean
keep your ass wear deodorant make sure
you smell good dress nice clean your
shoes
that's all obvious don't be on your
phone the whole time just be your
cleanest
you know what actually if you're not
like that
usually then just [ __ ] be nasty as
[ __ ] and see if someone looks
nah nah you know i don't know you might
find another nest i did learn to love
your bo
but if i if i made it on the first date
i'll be like wow it's kind of like girls
how there's i've heard that there's a
lot of girls that they would go
on first dates without any makeup and
like look i do that like really like
from oh that's where i heard it
yeah yeah really i do i do like minimal
makeup
because it's like all right well this is
what you're going to get and like it
usually works out fine and then later on
it's just like all right here's me
really trying yeah because yeah it's
instead of just
like just super kicked on makeup and now
i'm just like well [ __ ] now i have to
keep on trying
you know i get that opposite that's true
i never even thought of that before
yeah yeah yeah start with the the what
is it bar low
yeah set the bar alone create no
expectations and impress everyone when
you try
that's how i got through life um desense
says
uh tips for preparing for a hookup
please grooming
looks vibe make sure your ass is clean
sure your ass is clean that's a common
thing now well if you're a girl you
definitely have to shave
every inch of your body if you're that
tired yeah i mean i'm that type i'll
shave
my legs i shave my arms and i shave my
vagina
shave your actual arm yeah oh
i don't have hairy arms and my armpits i
[ __ ] shave my entire body basically
i did try shaving my face once a long
time ago but that was for like a beauty
trend that i was going microblading oh
no micro no people were just like girls
were just shaving their face for
dermaplaning dermaplaning yeah yeah um
uh what else do i do
if you can't see the crevices yeah
people think they're clean
dude i'd do that i [ __ ] i'll take a
shower and i'll take a mirror
i'll [ __ ] clean that [ __ ] out i'm
like yeah clean it up
it looks like you get off as you're
cleaning yeah you got to save it in just
in case you missed the date because
you're just unless you're a guy
i heard that that was a good that was
the thing that guys do is they jerk off
before
the first sometimes but if they're like
in their 30s i feel like then they won't
want to hook up after and it's totally
pointless
well maybe like i'm just really paying
attention because yeah if they're that
stressed out what you do is you get a
hand mirror like a nice big hand mirror
when you're shaving right
and then you squat over the mirror real
quick so you can see if you miss any
spots and that's how you make sure that
yeah
because when i was younger i would shave
the front and i would kind of skip some
of the back and then
like later on i'm kind of like wait a
minute yeah i have like a whole mullet
situation
so batch back there like i had like a
hairy butthole and i didn't know
dude same and like for some reason the
hair back there was straight
yeah i'm like weird why are you not cute
like it's like straight hair silky just
kind of yeah it's like this it's like a
word
wow
[Laughter]
when people ask for ass bangs they're
like oh hell yeah but not with nikki no
it means totally something different
it's not banging her ass she wants to
just show you her lies
about getting bangs anyway right now i'm
just going to say no
because i'm just thinking about ass
bangs bangs
don't do it what else uh thank you
because you have a small petite face and
it will make your face look even smaller
smaller that's right
the reason why i want to get the baby i
mean this is deriving off of the topic
but
it's because it's because my my hairline
keeps getting further and further back
and i'm getting scared how about side
bangs no it's not
my hair is thinning out especially
without seeing like going out in the sun
like the vitamin d is making me like
thinner hair i don't know but i'm like
dude i need to cover this freaking
hairline it's getting crazy it looks
good you got a good hairline dude yeah
really you're so sweet yeah you don't
have a long forehead at all yeah okay
thank you okay
sorry that's a girl yeah you're fine
you're good don't worry i would say you
got a brush
you gotta floss brush your teeth brush
your tongue brush your tongue
oh yes brush your why people don't
tongue
after you eat food yeah what kind of
food would you eat well
before i actually have a daily harvest
subscription
and that is true i i pay for it um too
but
i uh i don't know about you but
sometimes i feel like i need a summer
vacation from cooking a cake cause like
you know it's hot in the kitchen
sometimes you want to just grab
something out of your freezer pop it in
the microwave or your blender or
wherever
i also love that they have ice cream
options too it's
it's like vegan ice cream i love i
haven't gotten
i love love love the snack bites i've
been recently eating the daily harvest
the cacao nibs and
that one yeah the cacao with the uh
chickpea
yeah chicken it's almost like cookie
dough bites it's so good yeah i love it
it's great i i actually really enjoy um
almost everything i've tried there um so
right now daily harvest is helping me
beat the heat with the refreshing
smoothies and
delicious scoops the scoops is what it's
called the ice cream is called scoops
their new plant-based ice cream i do the
i did all of the flavors but my
especially like the black sesame
it's like salted caramel black sesame or
something like that salted
yeah really good eating clean food with
daily harvest is easy and effortless
whether you're having a night at home or
need a quick bite on the go everything
stays fresh in your freezer until you're
ready to enjoy it
uh keep it simple this summer with daily
harvest go to dailyharvest.com and enter
promo code big mood to get 25
off your first box that's promo code big
mood
for 25 off your first box
dailyharvest.comdailyharvest.com
promo code big mood yeah wow
and then uh there's nothing to tie it to
this next hour what you're going to wear
to the date
any clothes for the day yes you do need
clothes for your day wouldn't you love
if every clothing store you shopped at
already knew what you wanted to buy
it would save so much time and i have
shopping anxiety i don't know if that's
anything but it just drives me nuts
because i always i just get frustrated
constantly
but stitch fix is a company that will
help you they're focused on making
your styling goals happen get help from
someone who gets what you're going for
without ever leaving home
with a stitch fix styling expert to get
started
you set up your profile they'll deliver
great looks personalized just for you in
your color style and budget
you pay a 20 styling fee for each fix
but it'll be credited towards anything
you keep you can schedule at any time
and there's no subscription
required plus shipping returns and
exchanges are easy and
free get started today at stitchfix.com
mood and you'll get 25 off when you keep
everything in your box that's
stitchfix.com
for 25 off when you keep everything in
your
oh they call it a fix stitchfix.com
slash mood
i wore a whole outfit of stitch fix
today i got your fix yeah
i'm not wearing it now i took it off
before i put on these pjs
i just want to fire off some of a few
advice for hookup nights girls wear a
cotton thong
because it silences your farts i'm
telling you right now you can't eat a
lot of farts
it doesn't make a difference for me you
never know because you might sleep over
and you don't know what you had for
dinner that night assuming he took you
to dinner because you deserve it
no it has to be a it has to be a nice
thick
fabric thong not just like a string okay
because that doesn't cover enough you
know what
it's on days yeah or do you just go in
the bathroom and like
fart no because like he might be
sleeping next to you or like you can't
control your farts when you're sleeping
are you just waiting all you do is yes
stretch your butt
but you're not awake i'm talking about
like when you're sleeping you
accidentally fart in your sleep
well he can't judge you for that though
everyone knows the rules you gotta [ __ ]
him so good he'll be passed
out yeah not here but it has to be like
a thick
thong like a thong thong not a g string
because it's a string
because strings don't cover the whole
the starfish it has
the last time you wore a g string that's
what i'm saying i don't know anymore
all the way down because it acts like a
silencer it gives a nice space between
your cheeks there's no
you know like or like the girl said you
spread the butthole and it you know
uh also if you have to poop uh if they
turn on if they have the fan turn on the
fan also
lay down some toilet paper in in the
bowl first in the water first before you
poop so it doesn't make that splashing
sound
oh i'm not sure you're watching oh i
like to try to slide it in the water
oh see just put some toilet paper i try
my best to take a [ __ ] before i go on a
date or hook up
so sometimes it doesn't work that way
like put on the water the
the faucet that's the water weren't
are we still in a drought i don't know
water
okay how often are you gonna maybe poop
tiff's worried about those 30 seconds of
water don't waste water it adds up
there's a million people in this okay i
do a thing
and just take one less shower
okay i do a thing and you guys are all
gonna judge me for it and i'm prepared
for that
okay well you just judged her from
[ __ ] putting her water on while she
takes a [ __ ]
so we're gonna give it to you this is a
judging safe space okay
okay so what i do to silence the
the poops right so i i get paper i cover
my hand in paper
and then i kind of guide the poop out
will you catch your poop
yes i catch my foot catcher and then
like oh
no no i don't touch it with my actual
hands can we make it the thumbnail and
like the title of this video because
that is
done i'm judging hard now i'm accepting
your judgments
it's okay you could be a water waster or
a poop
i'm trying to process this but i i'm
feeling kind of empty inside and i'm not
really sure how i should feel
wait till you're full later and try
guiding it out try guiding it out damn
the [ __ ] that we go through to not get
embarrassed
what does it have like what if it's like
not solid
oh like what if you kind of have
diarrhea because you drink
like you know like you ever get like
tequila shits and you like drink too
much
and you just do gina's trick spread your
butt and then when it comes out it's
quiet
yeah i i'm very i'm just i'm really
think i'm ready to cut the episode right
now
um if it's like that it just sounds like
too much
it sounds like pee anyway that's true i
will
i will probably turn the shower on
because i feel like a shower has like
less
gallons per minute and it's louder you
really care about mother nature in this
[ __ ] huh i'm just trying to get laid
like did you take a shower i'm like
you're all dry yeah i don't take very
many showers during the week so i feel
pretty confident about like i take a
[ __ ] in the morning when i drink my
coffee so i don't really have these [ __ ]
problems
i took it once a day just drink a lot of
coffee in the morning take your shits in
the morning and don't take a [ __ ] during
a date
half this episode is about [ __ ] just
excuse yourself and go home
it's not going to get any better you
don't have sex don't have sex after you
take a [ __ ] because then you got ass you
got [ __ ]
traumatized burn your butt
hey judge me all you want okay okay i
appreciate the effort it's just
for a hookup okay how about for guys uh
manscaping
we are not sponsored but literally
manscaping
i prefer manscaping for sure i like that
a trim it doesn't have to be smooth just
a trim
yeah yeah i don't want it to tickle my
nose also i don't like when guys
if they have really thick facial hair or
really thick body hair i don't like when
they shave the day of the date because
then it's like that five make eye
contact with what's happening
she can't look at tiff anymore
go ahead but i'm talking about the you
know when guys have really thick facial
hair and they shave like that same day
but then it's been like two hours so
it's starting to come out and it's like
yeah it's like super rough like i'd
rather a guy like let his
facial hair grow out for like a couple
weeks where it's soft again
or his even his chest hair where it's
soft again when it grows out sometimes
it grows in patchy for them and that's
why they don't want to have it but if
it's that thick though to where it's
going to hurt me when it's shaved
it's not that patchy that's true that's
true uh even if you did shower before
the date if you guys are hooking up
later on
uh go in the bathroom and wash your dick
a little bit you know because you might
get you might have
been like five hours yeah a few hours
met her or showered yeah
yeah also i don't give blow jobs um to
people that aren't my boyfriend so i
wouldn't be doing this on a first date
but
if you're just a hooker expecting
friends with a blow job
um if you don't wash your dick sometimes
there's like little pubic hairs that
stick to it and then like the girl's
like and then it gets stuck in your
teeth yeah i'm just like
hey i learned something from my friend
you know how like you ever like
he ever or you guys ever go down on each
other and there's like a maybe like
something stuck in your tongue like a
hair or something yeah instead of making
it awkward like a
yeah what you do is you just start
licking their thighs until it comes off
but then they have like their eyes yeah
but then like
then another one will come off yeah
you're like a light roller i'm not
really licking
[Laughter]
it'll go further down my [ __ ] room
it's like in my throat on the couch
right there to be fair this advice is
from a guy
so the girl is licking is not as hairy
on the thighs stupid
just lick her eyes like oh yeah and then
he'll lick it until the hair comes off
there's trouble
so i guess she has hair i'm like bald
like a baby so
same same yeah laser um all right that's
wow we went on that for a while i liked
it i there were things that
there was a lot that happened i did not
want to know i um
i have questions that i don't want
answers to i don't give a [ __ ]
well you do you catch it you literally
you
have to get shits okay and you can
literally give it to them if you wanted
to
oh wow um uh jessica everyone's gonna
think
every single time i take a [ __ ] yeah
it's not guys you're catching it every
time you don't want to be embarrassed
wait so it's like the drop that you're
trying to avoid exactly
i feel like the drop like people don't
really hear the drop from the other
room as much as they hear like farts
that come out yeah
jeez you gotta spread them man yeah have
you ever caught one that just surprised
you like oh that's a hefty one
i'm sorry like i just it's a little bit
absolutely um
those are little pellets no doesn't it
soak through the paper a little
no it doesn't
like how long do you hold it before you
drop i don't it's
i said i guide it oh she gently places
it down okay so she doesn't catch and
then drop can't you release
it catch you really hold it for a while
have you ever actually missed the paper
and it hit the hand oh no
no you put like a lot of paper on there
no i don't like to wait that's always
i was testing you to see if you were
consistent with your mother nature oh
yeah you are consistent if anything here
at
big mood we are very very eco-friendly
yes i am too much all right i
cannot wait to move to the next answer
question all right uh jasmine zoo says
if you can switch lives with someone in
the group who would it be
like i don't know maybe jess i always
think just two
because i'm the single one yeah you guys
want to be [ __ ] you're single
and you're secretly want to be horn
nicki doesn't she's like i have a happy
marriage that's good
i'm actually good she's happy yeah i uh
maybe just because she's single and
she's running around and doing whatever
the [ __ ] she wants she has a cute
apartment
two dogs you could have all the same
[ __ ] though yeah but i want it already
readily done
so if i can just all you gotta do is get
rid of a couple things and switch a
couple things around you could have it
tomorrow i wish that i had the part of
jess's brain that wants to clean
no oh my god yeah like i like my place
in my life but like it's very
not clean and like i don't have
motivation to clean yeah
jess is very very tidy and i love it
like i'll see one spot and then like
three feet more there's another spot and
then another
then i'll waste like six hours i don't
have that i wish i did i i can tap into
that mentality i don't have it all the
time
i don't have to but i do it enough to
where it's always or how about traits
from each other that we wish that we had
i wish i had gina's
gaming life that's tight i think that's
pretty cool like
i i've never been able to figure out how
to stream things
so i can help you i want to thank his
creativity
so freaking creative like it blows my
mind like i'm always so like in
awe from your creativity i'm like dude
and then i want gina's [ __ ] talking
skills like really like roasting people
that's [ __ ] good
years or two but years of childhood
trauma yeah yeah very great money all of
those
and i want your tits and i want all yes
i don't have [ __ ] ten thousand
dollars though i also kind of wish i had
a kid
that was like a fully a fully grown kid
yeah because i don't want a baby like if
you could deliver me a 12 year old i'd
probably deal with it i don't want a
[ __ ] baby though but you have to go
through the struggles of
getting that but i don't want to i just
want to like a kid that's my friend
already
i know it's so fun yeah i love it i
would zero in on
you right now as a mom but not yeah i
don't want to [ __ ] do the whole [ __ ]
i wish i had the decorating skills of
jess and tiff tips tips
really good damn yeah and you're
standing i i hear you
i i like your decorating but i can't see
it over the mess
but i appreciate the mess my bedroom's
clean yes
oh you know what your bathroom's nice
yeah your bedroom's great yeah yeah i
like your bedroom and the patio is
[ __ ] dope
yeah you're awesome i like your office
too oh thanks
yeah yes yeah i like to pull it out yeah
yeah yeah yeah
areas that you did actually complete are
actually really great yeah i think
that's what it is
it's just because of recently yeah she's
done everything so it like stands out
because the whole thing is [ __ ]
decorated whereas like you have
corners it's also like a [ __ ] mess
right now because i was gonna redecorate
the bathroom
and then i stopped and so there's just
boxes everywhere in my
in my place like it's fascinating to me
like i remember i went over to nikki's
house she's like oh and this is like a
towel rack that i'm gonna install i'm
like
yourself yeah wow chandeliers dude i
know she did yeah
i did the electricity on the chandeliers
too i tried to unscrew a light bulb once
and i broke it
oh my god yeah the screw got stuck in
there well you're very aggressive when
you approach
things you're just like [ __ ] shattered
in my head
you're really thin it didn't work how
did you get out this group
yeah i had to go online and they i an
apple and then i learned that you're
supposed to
stick an apple or carrot to get it out
and what i actually
ended up doing was just throwing the
whole lot out and buying a new one
[Applause]
um and then from nikki i would like more
i like i wish i can be more um
for me when someone does something wrong
to me i'm like i'm gonna kill that
person
that's just how it is now where you're
gonna die but nikki's like well
how about this like how about you know
be kinder and try to understand what's
going on and like
you know don't act like that you know
here let's just do this the right way
don't cut someone's head off
i wish i can do that but nikki's like
she's the one who brings us back like
guys like we have to you know
we can't murder stop but then i hate
mom because she's like people not give
it to me
but then i come in and i'm like nikki
they're just venting it's okay
so they don't actually murder someone
and zip never says no she's like yes
okay well yeah maybe you guys can murder
them
and she's like there was a pail over my
eyes later i realized that brother is
wrong
i'm sorry i didn't see that so i wish i
had that from nikki
i mean there's deep really [ __ ] nice
like oh there's deeper [ __ ] that i like
there's just your gaming i'm a lot like
yeah
god damn it you went to real [ __ ] all
right i like i like your tits yeah
that's about it it's all surface here um
yeah i mean i'm not as mean as i usually
am on the internet i'm actually
super you're so sweet sweetest i just
don't i love your
your your i don't know if i i'll call it
a habit or whatever but like you
the way that you just touch yeah i love
yours
you're also like you're really
thoughtful like you'll just send random
gifts and stuff
like don't tell them the gift i got i
love you she
told me she's like what's your address
i don't know where this is going but i
mean either way like something really
sweet or i'm setting a mariachi band at
four in the morning
uh so i give her my address and about a
week later i get a gift a surprise gift
in the mail
and it was when we were at the height of
our animal crossing
uh [ __ ] addiction and i open it up
and it's some coasters
and if you play animal crossing you
understand this joke but
um the coaster says you a broke [ __ ]
timmy and tommy and tommy yeah and the
so the first one says you're broke [ __ ]
and then stuff you broke [ __ ]
and this second one says [ __ ]
cause they finished cute the one he just
only says the last word of the
yeah and also you broke in that game
i saw that i was like nikki needs to
have this right it's the best it's my
coasters on my desk
i think it's what i do is it's a it's
very tough love
yeah it's what i do but you know what
like you guys know whenever i'm
with friends or like when i have close
friends i'm very very
writer invested very invested yeah yeah
okay
enough about how great i am uh
let's see uh we already talked about
this question before so i'm going to
skip it but i do just want to point out
the name was hilarious
for those of you who watch the show you
this person's username was joe
goldberg's hat
god bless i love you oh yeah it's
perfect i like that show
the next question is from namra namra
would like to know
how do you date with high standards like
how do i decide when to compromise or
not
nikki i feel like you're good at this
yeah well that's from a bunch of like
just settling you know like yeah after a
while you're like you know what
maybe i don't have to settle anymore and
so you just like you really have to map
out beforehand
what am i not willing to put up with for
the rest of my life because if there
if your end goal is to get married or be
with that partner
forever or a long period of time like
what are some things that you just can't
[ __ ] stand or you don't want to stand
for or you don't want to keep forgiving
someone for
and you set those boundaries and if they
put up any flags like some red flags and
you know to cut it off immediately
before you
get too many feels because if you ask
yourself that question
and the first thing that pops up is like
someone who
doesn't put the toilet seat down for
lack of a better example
and since that's the first thing that
popped into your head and you're like i
cannot do this now you know that if
someone were to do that's like all right
even if you're nice about it now it's
going to eat away at you later on and if
you let them know too yeah
i feel like there's a difference between
like actions or like
like values bad habits and then like
yeah like whole personalities yeah so
like
for me i was struggling uh when i was
dating uh because i met a guy that i
really liked but he
i saw him doing drugs and i was like
okay
i i kind of observed a little bit longer
because i was like is this just like an
action or like a or is this like a
personality
and so as time went on i started seeing
more and more okay this is a personality
this is like ingrained this is who he is
he loves to do
drugs right and i'm like [ __ ] because if
it was just a one-off thing or like
a recreational thing it's kind of like
he has all of these things that i like
about him
but then there's this thing that's
actually a personality trait
really yeah it's like but if it was just
like oh
you know he's not good at putting
something back in the kitchen the way i
like it i feel like that's
those aren't really things that that you
should really be fighting about or
worried about it's like you just kind of
like that's when to compromise it's like
okay he's never
going to be good at putting the toilet
seat down let it go
well that's why i said lack for a better
example yeah yeah but like it's
something bigger than
yeah you just have to discern like what
for you is
just little a little habit or something
or something that's ingrained in their
personality that's really just doesn't
match your yeah because i think that the
main thing is most people don't even
think about it beforehand they just
start going dating and then they
catch fields for somebody and then they
realize later that like i actually don't
like this and then they try to change
that thing
yeah that never [ __ ] works it just
creates friction for a long time until
you inevitably [ __ ] hate that person
one of my big deal breakers is i will
not deal with um
people who get drunk often and are
bad drunks because i grew up in a family
of there's a couple people in my family
that were
just [ __ ] alcoholics and i had to
deal with their [ __ ] when they're
drunk and
how like angry and [ __ ] that they are so
growing up like that's
my deal breaker like if you're a bad
drunk if i i remember
i was i was dating this guy and like uh
you know it went well for
you know a few dates and then on like
our fourth or fourth date he got so
drunk and like belligerent i was like oh
no that i'm not with that at all and i
cut it off like that's
but sometimes you know like maybe if you
if you bring it up like hey is this you
know like are you
this is like the thing of yours or like
well for me it's so
deeply ingrained in me that when i see
that i'm just turned off just
immediately no i can't do it
sorry yeah because it could just be like
a like a
one-off like it just kind of got out of
out of control i don't drink like this
often but for you it's like
nope yeah because like you might get
there like you don't even want someone
that can even get there
so it's it's like my history like once i
see it i'm just i can't turn it back on
it's too much of a
trigger yeah it's so much of a trigger
for me that i can't deal with it yeah i
definitely get that and and having to
cut things off with someone that you
like actually really like when there's
deal breakers like that or
or you're like then you start to
question yourself you're like oh well
should i compromise on this value of
mine because
but at the end of the day it's like no
there are other people out there and you
will meet the one
that has all the things you do like and
very little things that you don't like
and it'll be so much better
it's it's tough i mean like going
through that
yeah yeah what would have been you guys
as deal breakers
what that's an obvious one but
um i think as far as like the first
signs goes um
like if they're bad communicators i i
just won't i can't i refuse to deal with
it anymore
like it used to be really forgivable
like oh he hasn't texted me and then
and then i forgive them but then it
happens over and over and over again and
it hurts my feelings every time and like
i tell them that and then they don't do
it
and i'm just sick of it um so yeah
you're gonna be left feeling empty a lot
yeah if you don't text me or you can't
you
know communicate to me that you're busy
or whatever like you know then i
i just need that communication and it
doesn't make me feel safe
if it's not there yeah i think uh you
guys taught me actually because i was
having trouble with like hey
like he said he was gonna do this but he
didn't and am i too am i crazy for
feeling this way
and you guys told me like well no
because something was promised to you
and it didn't work out and that can lead
to that being a habit
yeah so when you allow broken promises
to happen yeah
it's just a gateway to a lot of things
exactly i never
really took into consideration all this
like
when i was dating before but if i would
ever
go into the dating world again oh man
there's a lot of things that i'm like
okay well now i can see the signs for
that and i know for sure i don't ever
want to get into that or whatever it is
so i think it all it's with experience
too like if you
yourself don't know what a a deal
breaker is
i mean it really just does take
experience and for you to actually get
to know yourself
and see like oh okay i've experienced
that i know i never want that again
that's now a deal break yeah like
wasting time for years and knowing that
people
really don't change then you're like
okay well i don't have to do it again
later so yeah
that's not a deal breaker for me is a
guy that doesn't know how to cook
uh i love guys that cook and uh hello
fresh makes it so easy
hello fresh offers so many recipes to
choose from each week
to help you break out of your recipe rut
and offers fresh high quality
ingredients
every week for a super flavorful
experience and it's so
easy to cook so if you want to impress
somebody on a date
i mean half the battle is getting them
to your house right and here you can
promise them with some food
uh hellofresh cuts out stressful meal
planning and grocery store trips
so you can enjoy cooking and get dinner
and table in just about 30 minutes or
even 20 minutes
if you're really good with their quick
recipe options
hello fresh is pretty really romantic
when someone cooks for you
yeah even if it's bad food it's like oh
that's really sweet you put a lot of
effort into this
but hella fresh is not bad i'll tell you
that right now
hello fresh's pre-portioned ingredients
means there's less prep for you and less
food waste it's actually
everything is pre-measured for you so
they really cannot mess this up love
that
hellofresh donated over 2.5 million
meals to charity in 2019 and this year
is stepping up their food donations amid
the coronavirus crisis
personally my favorite one and i've been
saying this for months now is the
cherry reduction pork chop oh my god
that's so
good and then like i get to post
pictures because there's a picture of it
how it's supposed to look so you know
what you're doing
and then i post pictures of it
pretending that i actually know how to
cook and people are like oh my god gina
you're so wifey material
now you can try out america's number one
meal kit
go to hellofresh.com big mood 80
and use the code big mood 80 to get a
total of 80
off including free shipping on your
first box additional restrictions apply
please visit hellofresh.com for more
details again go to hellofresh.com
big mood 80 and use code big mood 80 to
get a total of 80
off including free shipping on your
first box additional restrictions to
apply please visit hellofresh.com
for details and yes hellofresh is
delicious
but if you're not really filling up for
whipping up some food you can always hit
up
doordash so doordash is the app that
brings you food you're craving
right now right to your door ordering is
super easy you just open
the doordash app you choose what you
want to eat and your food will be left
safely outside your door with the new
contactless delivery drop-off setting
which is my ultimate favorite and i hope
it never goes back to the old way
because i really love
having no contact it's my favorite but
it's also my favorite getting food
just directly to my door i love that so
you can support your local go-to's
or you can choose from your favorite
national restaurants like chipotle when
day what chipotle
yeah hey one day mondays
basic
[Applause]
yeah exactly chipotle what what
holy wendy totally choose factories
chipotle
wendy's and a cheesecake factory so many
of your local favorite restaurants are
still open for delivery because you know
now with the pandemic happening
you can't really just dine in or
anything so just open the door dash app
select your favorite
local restaurant and your food will be
left to your door okay so right now
our listeners can get five dollars off
and zero delivery fees
on their first order of fifteen dollars
or more
when you download the doordash app and
enter code big mood
that's five dollars off and zero
delivery fees on your first order when
you
download the door dash app in the app
store
and enter code big mood don't forget
that's code
big mood for five dollars off your first
order with doordash
yay yeah um next question is from
jeffer611 saying what do you guys wish
men knew about women there's a lot
i'm just kidding where do we start yeah
right i'm just so i'm like depressed by
the thought of answering this question
i think women are all so different too
so when everyone's like
what do i need to understand about women
is like well i mean i'm sure men are
like this too
yeah but uh so case by case like if i
tell you everything that
i want you to understand about me it's
completely different than gina or tiff
or
anybody exactly uh i think one thing is
um for me at least i tend to
kind of overthink things and my mom has
always had to tell me like you need to
chill because
i'm like why isn't he talking to me why
isn't he
but him he's actually sitting there like
a nice bird in the sky i wonder where
that bird's going you know so it's like
um i tend to kind of over complicate
things a lot or i
i get so into my brain like take it
personally yeah yeah yeah like
do you still like me like if you don't
talk to me for two hours like do you
still like me you know and i need
that comfort and reassurance sometimes
it doesn't happen often
i feel like it's um it's just it's just
random sometimes and it just doesn't
make sense in my head like i've done
i've gone to you guys about this yeah
they're like gina are you [ __ ] stupid
you know like i get that way hormonally
too yeah yeah
yeah certain times of the month i'm like
i really need you to validate
that you love me exactly like other
times i'm like leave me alone
yeah like we can be at the altar and
i'll be like
they still love me like you know like it
just doesn't make sense sometimes i
can't make sense of it in my head
that's actually something that uh
i have so many moments when i stop and i
think
and i'm like [ __ ] what would i want him
to do right now to make me
happier and i'm like [ __ ] i really don't
know god damn it i'm so complicated
man why am i so complicated like i
really i try to figure out a solution
and there's a lot of emotions that i
mean it's not logical i think that's the
thing too some guys figured out like
say my dad he's figured it out if i'm
being emotional or this or that he kind
of just takes it in one ear not the
other and he doesn't let it affect him
and he doesn't really react to it
so sometimes i'm like why can't
boyfriends do that like
if like if i'm just being too emotional
or something or if i'm not being logical
that's actually something just don't let
it bother you so much like just
just understand that women are highly
emotional creatures
just do the bare minimum but don't be
patronizing with that i'm not
patronizing but just like don't
like figure out a way to like understand
that we're just wired that way
and then like not let it affect you yeah
i think that's like another
it goes back to the like how do you set
a standard you know
and i think that that's one of them is
that
guys that understand that part is
like that's so important to me and they
get along with women easier too because
they don't let women's emotions affect
them
yeah or like i don't like i've had guys
think that
you're not being logical if you're
having emotions like you can
do both like yeah i can be emotional
about something and like logically
understand that
i shouldn't be emotional about it and
it's not fair to
like count that against intelligence
yeah i wouldn't say that we're not
intelligent when we're being emotional
i think yeah it's a it's a tough line
it's like because i i know
i just know a lot of times where i'm
like feeling a certain way
and then they take it and then also
they'll hold on to it and i'm like well
i was just being emotional
yeah but logically i understand the
situation is this way but then they're
they're just like they're holding on to
that emotion because like it's important
to be
empathetic towards the emotions yeah and
that's what you mean i think is by like
oh not letting it fully affect
i'm taking it personally yeah exactly
but also understanding like
okay you have emotions that's fine you
don't have to like completely just sweep
it under the rug and it's like that
doesn't matter
like we can just ignore it it's that's
not the case either
there has to be like a fine line between
like understanding
and i think a level of like validation
too like when you're feeling
emotional you really need that that
validation that's what i mean by being
empathetic
right like validating our emotions but
without like it's almost like a
like feathers like water kind of like
just yeah
you don't have to logically understand
emotions emotions are not logical
like it doesn't cancel out your logic
part of your brain it just
the motion itself is not logical some
guys think it's the end of the world too
like it's never going to go away but we
experience like 50 emotions like within
the same 24 hours somebody's trying to
talk you out of it like well you
shouldn't feel sad because blah blah
blah i'm like i know that
yeah i just feel like i know it'll come
and it'll go
i actually have to deal with something
like that um so
okay so this stems back from when i was
like a kid right my grandparents were
[ __ ] insane so every morning they'd
wake me up by screaming
oh my god which is [ __ ] awful again
wake up now
clean the house like that's a terrible
way to wake up every day
it's extremely traumatic so um so keep
that
trauma in mind already and then there's
one morning where he woke up before me
and he was just playing with my gun
because i leave my gun unloaded
okay you're dating yeah the guy was
dating sorry um
and he like he cocked it cocked it and
then pulled the trigger
what well it's not loaded it's not
loaded oh okay yeah you just said you
keep it loaded so
unload it unloaded i keep it unloaded so
there's no magazine no okay
and it snaps back really loud and scared
the hell out of me and i woke up yeah
and then like it doesn't happen often
i'm not saying that every loud noise
will freak me out but for some reason
this one really freaked me out
and i like went into like a panic like
yeah you can't do that you you cannot do
that
i'm sorry but this is where it comes
from and um
it's it's i knew that this doesn't make
sense why am i reacting this way but i
couldn't stop it you can yeah you can't
help it you can't help it and then i
told him like
this is why i feel this way please like
i'm so sorry like can you please just
hug me i i feel
and then he took it as why are you
attacking me for something i didn't do i
didn't even know and he got angry
what yeah instead of comforting me no
and i'm like some guys are just dumb
they just don't understand
yeah he thought that i did like he
thought like why are you attacking me i
didn't do anything wrong
i just woke you up like this doesn't
make sense like you just woke up shocked
why did why are you freaking out
and i tried to explain to him like this
is a trauma
i cannot control this and like um
he like so he was mad that i was upset
you know and he couldn't understand it
because he's never been through anything
like that
yeah so i was when i get really worked
up i have like an emergency pack of
cigarettes
i was going outside i was gonna go
outside to smoke but then i realized
no i like i need to nip this in the bud
i need to talk to him about it so he
understands so i went back to the room
and i said
i know that we're having kind of a spat
right now we're both tired we just woke
up
but i really need your help right now i
need you to calm me down because i'm
freaking out and then that's
when he heard me say i need your help
yeah that's when he was just like
oh okay okay what do i do you know
because some
guys get defensive right i'm not
attacking you this is i'm trying to
explain so that's when he was like okay
okay come here it's okay
so um i i i wish that people
like some guys i guess i'm not gonna say
not all men
but um i'm we're not attacking you yes
we just can't really you know control
what's going on and we're trying to tell
you like please don't do this i'm not
attacking you but this is why i feel
this way
yeah i i hate when i'm trying to explain
something too but the emotions are
taking over
and then it's still coming off like they
are still taking it personally
just because the emotions are there and
i'm just like i'm just trying to explain
something to you and
yeah there's all these emotions here he
got like kind of mean because he's like
so you're mad because i woke you up it's
just like dude no that's not how that
works like and i you would have to
sometimes with men you have to explain
to them like they're five years old you
know
like when they don't when they haven't
experienced it and the hard part
is when sometimes they're not receptive
even though you're like literally
just spelling it out and then that that
whole thing about getting angry at you
when you're just like
but this is the reason and then they get
angry like that is the most infuriating
frustrating
like disappointing like heartbreaking
emotion where you're just like
what the [ __ ] dude like i'm really
trying to tell you and explain to you
like this is why it is
and and you're you're taking it as a
personal attack and it just
it's really disheartening yeah exactly
or like you can't get don't get mad at
me for reacting this way that i can't
control or people just get mad because
you're mad
it's like wait a minute now i have to
apologize to you like that no that's not
yeah that's the most immature response
ever
and i know what yeah it just it sucks
dealing with that personality
yeah so i mean like coming back to the
question what we wish men knew about us
it it varies so much per person but i
guess it's just like trying to
understand
emotions and how to react to women's
emotions could be a starter for
a general yeah yeah listen
yeah i think listen just listening
exactly um
all right now for the last question of
the day a little bit lighter something a
little bit lighter
dc trays would like to know would you
date younger guys and what do you think
about that
i don't think i ever can because i have
so much fun
it's just weird and you had him young so
yeah it's like that age gap is already
not that big it's only an 18-year age
gap
yeah i've only dated younger by like two
years once and that was a disaster yeah
yeah it was a guy that i made the video
about like that was
never again i know if i've ever dated
anyone younger than me yeah i really
more to like older men
i feel like right because guys are just
so excited you guys are so immature
already yeah
exactly wasn't that like generally like
a common
commonly known thing that like guys just
take forever to mature so then
women tend to be attracted to older guys
because then they're they meet the same
maturity level
yeah basically um gosh i feel like
i think i'm just thinking of jada you
know like dating a younger guy but yeah
no i don't
i don't know i think like for a serious
relationship i mean he would have to be
oh because we have friends that um
jun and dan right oh yeah he's he's like
five or six years
uh younger younger than her so yeah and
they work out really well so i guess
it's a stacy too right
oh yes this is worse yeah so i mean
there's definitely guys
if they're mature enough then i would
totally i mean it's really just about
maturity levels my grandparents
um they were best friends well before my
grandma died but um
they were best friends and they're nine
years apart and he was nine years
younger than wow
that's a huge difference for a guy
that's yeah that's okay
but they were both older when they met
so okay yeah
i mean once you're in your 30s like once
you pass 30 35
yeah like you're kind of so he was like
35
and then she was like 40. something yeah
yeah there's a huge difference between
that and like 30 and then 21.
yeah that's a huge difference there's
just way too much growth for all the
laughs
dude even right now i see these like
celebrity guys
that are like like uh shawn mendes
you know like he was doing this thing
with like camilla that song that they
have together and like in the music
video and all these girls are like
sooning over him and all this and i'm
like
i can't i can't even see him like
remotely attractive to me because he's
just so much younger and to me that like
eliminated style
the style of the young boys too like
yeah i don't know it's not attractive
like i guess maybe because we're getting
older yeah we're just older i think
you want a guy that's like because we're
at that age we're like i don't want to
give a [ __ ]
about looks and image and all that [ __ ]
anymore like there's
a lot of that in your 20s is like you
know like true trying to be cool
yeah trying to look cool and stuff and
you're just over it in your 30s
and there's just so much for them to
learn i don't feel like raising someone
yeah
i mean like like our friends or some
people you might meet
there's some unicorn guys unicorns yeah
yeah but
i don't want to raise anyone right now i
don't want to teach you how to be
considerate or like hey you can't do
that you know
i think i saw this tweet once it was
negated afterwards but whatever
there's a tweet that says jennifer lopez
says that men aren't useful until
they're 33
and up and then another person said well
yeah but that [ __ ] collects engagement
rings like thanos so i don't know if you
want to trust me
so you know like it's
it's men mature a lot differently maybe
35 or 37 would be more like it
yeah i guess it would depend on maturity
level and the majority
of guys that are younger seem to be less
mature like if a 25 year old came up to
me i would probably absolutely never
give him a chance
that happened we went out once like
earlier this year before quarantine we
went bar hopping me and jess because we
got
oh yeah that one young man hit on me
yeah and this one young guy
really wanted he was all over it he was
like
26 he was 26 and
jess was still like you're a baby and
i'm like that yeah
like she was like you should just do it
he definitely was a little bit more
immature though
for sure he was like talking about his
music producing career like you know
just like really fronting hard
yeah so yeah i get it i get it i can't
do it now but also i was like but don't
you just want to hook up
i mean i i i think i would do a hookup
yeah yeah he didn't he didn't come
through though
yeah oh wow he probably couldn't get a
ride from his parents um yeah
yeah but yeah but whenever it comes to
like a younger guy now i don't
see it as like a i'm just like oh that's
that's really cute yeah
you're so cute you know like it just
feels weird i don't know i'm just used
to like
looking up to a man versus that yeah
like i would be looking down to a man
yeah because i want to feel like
[Music]
them and um it and like what would you
like for dinner today
and not like i'll ask my mom to make us
some dinner i don't want that yeah you
know
like that's that's that's not impossible
but he'd have to be quite a man
quite a man quite a man there are
unicorns out there they're not a good
man there are unicorns on your parents
like yours i keep looking yeah unicorn
slippers
i kind of want to ask that to guys too
like would you date
a significantly older woman i think a
lot of guys would i think they would too
yeah
that's true that's true all we need is
all yeah
thank you thank you thank you bonus
episode the bonus slumber party the big
ass
mood and i'm ready for the judgment you
know oh
over here you had to remind them you
didn't even have they might have
forgotten by now i know no they didn't
i did it i know you did it because they
did her and i need you to judge me on it
exactly they didn't forget so i know you
guys didn't forget
so i'm like hey there's probably like a
something like front hand or backhanded
yeah
never i still have more questions i'm
down to answer them
all right well i feel like there's a
porno like that somewhere
two girls one cup oh my god like a guy
watching okay i'm gonna cut this off now
before we lose our sponsors
poop throwers four all right guys thank
you guys so much for watching
um make sure you guys subscribe like the
video comment below on
the poop catcher no guider
the guy oh poop guider you know what's
her instagram is at real
i'm really i'm really trying really hard
to just be comfortable and okay with it
but inside i'm dying i'm like oh
you guys are judging me everyone's got
some weird i still love you
wait who said that wait you also said
you chew on your toenails too right oh
that was a different
no i don't currently
thanks for watching everybody we love
you thanks for asking the questions
we'll be doing this
more so leave it down below
yeah we'll be asking you guys answer
some questions sometimes so follow us on
instagram all of our links are down
below
bye everybody i'm going to restrict your
comments if you become an ig
i'm restricting your ass